money rocks where we expose crime
corruption and shocking betrayals of
public
[Music]
trust I'm Eric bowling and welcome to
money rocks with the anniversary of 911
tensions are running high with a ground
zero at the building of the ground zero
mosque there are planned protests at the
site and the NYPD has called up a quote
Army of extra officers to help keep
things under control opinions have been
strong on both sides and tonight we'll
hear from our Allstar panel on the left
we have attorney Joey Jackson inside
scoop radio host Mark Lavine and on the
right Fox News contributor contributor
Andrea tantos uh we're going to get to
the panel in a few minutes hang tight
stay with us but first let's welcome
Pamela Geller from stop islamization of
America now Pam you're holding a 911
event what's it all about set the stage
for us tomorrow at 3:00 on the corner of
West Broadway in Park Place we're
holding a human rights rally a remember
rally of those who were slaughtered 9
years ago and against Islamic
supremacism um I noticed some of the
families of people who lost uh loved
ones in the World Trade Center were
saying don't hold it simultaneously with
the 911 tribute are you is that the
reason for your 3:00 well it's well
after the Memorial Services uh I
considered moving it but I was implored
by many scores of 911 family members who
will be speaking not to move the rally
we have many human rights activists is
speaking uh from Sudan Coptic Christians
um Muslim uh Iranians this will be a an
effort to appeal to the Imam to move
this this Islamic supremacist mosque in
a building that is Ground Zero not 600
feet from Ground Zero Eric it is ground
Z is Ground Zero I agree with you 100%
Pam Geller hang in there for a minute I
want to get to we're going to get back
to you in a minute but with us now from
the NASDAQ site is New York
representative Peter King representative
this day hit you hard you lost a lot of
people from your District they were
killed on 911 set the stage for us sir
from your
perspective well uh I lost uh probably
150 friends neighbors constituents on
September 11th uh to this day it's a
tragedy that's ongoing uh Ian I can't
walk more than a few blocks without
seeing a street sign uh which is named
after a police officer a firefighter who
was murdered on September 11th you go to
church you walk into the fames you go to
a diner you go to a bagel shop I mean
the friend the uh the relatives the
parents the brothers the sisters the
widows the widowers they're everywhere
and it's a it's a tragedy it's going to
live with us but so so will the courage
so will the courage of those who uh
sacrificed so much on September 11th and
also those who were still sacrificing
today those who became ill at Ground
Zero uh and have these horrible
debilitating illnesses today those who
are fighting in Iraq and Afghanistan so
to me the memory of 9/11 will always be
there and I certainly will do all that I
can to help those who were there that
day and also I am of course right now in
also on the whole issue involving the
mosque sir um well let's go you brought
it up about the ground zero mosque first
of all would you agree it is Ground Zero
Ground Zero mosque I I believe it is I
mean the fact that the landing gear uh
went directly from the plane to that
building makes it almost part of the
crime scene I also believe that uh to be
barely 500 feet from ground zero to be a
13 story $100 million edifice certainly
it it'll be the a a dominant site there
at Ground Zero I believe it's being put
there as far you know to make a
statement not to build Bridges but to
make a statement representative uh no
doubt you read the Imam R oped in the
New York Times from I believe it was
Wednesday we actually went down to the
ground zero MOS site to rebut that oped
um in it he he uses the words like at a
terrible cost in other words if we not
not force him but really push him or
even if he chooses to move the Mosk on
his own it may be at the expense of
Americans abroad he came out on CNN talk
to Christian alore on ABC also three
different occasions he's been fairly
insightful does that concern you yes it
does to me it's almost as if he's
blackmailing or threatening the United
States and somehow if uh if his mosque
is not approved or people speak out
against his mosque we have to worry
about being attacked by Islamic
terrorists uh and to me uh you know our
country is too strong for that and we
don't have to be proving ourselves to
anyone around the world we've allowed
more freedom for Muslims and Catholics
Protestants Jews all all religions and
all non-believers in this country than
anywhere in the world I don't think
there's any country in the world where
Muslims have more freedom and
opportunity than they have here in the
United States we don't have to prove
ourselves to anyone we certainly don't
have to measure up to some standard set
by anima who said that the US was a
co-conspirator by 911 or access to 911
we exactly there were several comments
from earlier I guess in the year and
then several comments post 91 where he
actually almost I guess he said that
Osama Bin Laden was I think he said hate
to do this wrong but made in the USA is
that right he did which is not true at
all to begin with and secondly to be
saying that so soon after September 11
to me showed a tremendous callousness
and an indifference to what we were
going through I mean you know can you
imagine somebody in the 1940s uh after
we learned of the atrocities were
carried up by Hitler saying well perhaps
the Jews were also accessories to this
or after Pearl haror saying that the US
was an accessory to Pearl Harbor no this
to me uh shows that his uh that he is
very mixed feelings and that this whole
idea of being a bridge build I just
don't accept all right sir just give us
a quick uh minute on what what are you
doing at the NASDAQ site sir yeah which
is entirely separate from the Mosk let
me make that clear I'm down here with
the post 911 Foundation gentleman here
with me Charlie wasel who was a marine
he was also a police officer who became
Gravely ill at Ground Zero the post 911
Foundation is set up to first of all
help those who uh served at Ground Zero
to uh memorialize What uh what was done
and also to provide continuing care and
support for those who are at Ground Zero
and also those veterans uh from Iraq and
Afghanistan those who are fighting
terrorism around the world proud to be
here representative King thank you very
much for taking the time to join us
thank you all right Pam I want to bring
you back into the conversation now also
joining us from Washington is the
chairman of the New Black Panther Party
Malik shabaz but first Pam take a look
at this map of the ground zero area
showing where body parts were found
we're going to throw it up um that's the
lower manhatt area you can see red dots
if you look carefully you can see some
red dots the interesting part is there
there's a DOT that shows where the
proposed site of the ground zero mosque
would be there are no red dots there Pam
but there are no red dots there because
they haven't checked it for body parts
yet also take a look at this piece of
landing gear that crashed through the
roof Mr Peter King uh representative
King uh referenced that that's a piece
of the landing gear from one of the
airplanes crashed right through the roof
of the ground zero mosque is this the
kind of stuff that drives you crazy Pam
well don't spit in our face and tell us
that it's raining uh clearly he's
threatening us with Jihad and these this
idea of that they'll respond they'll
respond to us with violence just
validates the whole idea of uh the
ideology behind uh the 911 attacks is it
not the same thing and where are you
going to draw the line where are you
going to draw the line where if we do
this or we do that we have to be afraid
of getting attacked you have the Muslim
Student Association who wants Halal
cafeterias who wants uh you know
segregated gyms and segregated dorms and
what happens if we don't do it is that
going to piss off the jihadis well let
let me bring in uh Mr Malik shabbaz sir
um could you give us your reaction to a
couple of these images that we're
showing on the
screen I can't see what you're showing
on the screen but I can tell you that
this whole attitude of intolerance and
bigotry towards Muslims in America is
very ignorant and it's immature and you
will not be able it appears to move the
mosque the president of the United
States said they had the right to build
it and so therefore I think you should
take the opportunity to learn more about
Islam and the valuable contributions
that Islam has made to American society
and the value that Islam has brought to
the world sir all due respect all due
respect we we we've spent a lot of time
we've had a lot of guests we've we've
done this story for a good portion of
our show every night for the past month
sir we've had all points of view what do
you object to I'm not sure what you're
what you're saying where am I
islamophobe I'm trying let me get let me
ask you that yes yes yes I think that
what Americans need to try to do is to
understand why is the prophet Muhammad
the bust of the founder of Islam inside
of the Supreme Court why is the George
Washington Thomas Jefferson and the
early American Presidents why were they
Shriners who studied the Quran and
studied Islam in secret so there's not
been the dialogue to learn about Islam
nor the dialogue to learn about Muslim
suffering me only not only allow me to
do this listen for for the record got to
learn for the record I I was down there
I was in the World Trade Center my our
audience knows all about that and I'm
not going to rehash that I asked for the
Imam Imam R please move the mosque I
want you to move it I don't I understand
you don't have to we're asking you to on
the same talk sir sir in the same vein I
would say the same exact thing to the
pastor Terry Jones in Florida in
Gainesville don't burn the Quran because
it's insensitive my point is don't burn
the Quran because it's insensitive also
move the mosque because building one
there would be insensitive as well well
it's I think it's also insensitive to
Muslims and I think as much as we are
being acts to empathize with the victims
of 9911 we should empathize with the
victims of predator drones and innocent
Muslims who are being murdered by
hundreds of thousands across the Earth
so if we would take a mature approach if
we would take a approach and study the
suffering of the oppressed and the
Muslims as well as the suffering of
white Americans then we could have a
dialogue that could make sense
islamophobia islamophobia is a
fallacious argument used to shut people
up there is no reciprocity we're
constantly being schooled in this hyp
sensitivity in the Muslim world this
extraordinary sensitivity you can run
the Danish cartoons and the media didn't
in some in in a somewhat self-enforced
Sharia you can't say the prophet
Muhammad on Comedy Central you can't run
when we you can't run wa I'm speaking
I'll let you speak sir you can't run the
Prophet Muhammad in a Huggy Bear costume
so we have this hyp sensitivity to the
Muslim world and yet there's no
reciprocity where is the mutual and
mutual respect where is the mutual and
mutual understanding where is the
tolerance and I have to tell you
something sir this idea of 75% of the
American people are deeply offended by
this sir they're
deeply there are many many people of all
colors not the black but guess what but
not the blacks because in America you
say you love Muhammad Ali Muhammad Ali
was a Muslim and so blacks are not as
black blacks are not as upset okay well
if you love Muslims then let them build
the mosque and learn if you want to
study anything from 9911 try to study
why some Muslims are mad at America pam
pam please sir just ask study why some
Muslims are mad at America that would be
productive and therapeutic Mr Mr I'm not
mad Muslims I'm simply saying the MOs of
Ground Zero mosque being built on that
location is insensitive don't do it
equally as insensitive equally as
insensitive would be burning the Quran
in Gainesville I'm saying don't do that
either why say is I don't say that
they're equal that they have a right to
build there and you should take it as a
learning experience to again learn the
contributions of Islam to why we always
being why is a ISL ISL why isn't it a
two
C basic look you can't this is a basic
fundamental pain and it's not
extraordinarily listen I've been
studying Islam for 9 years and it's not
about Islam it's about this idea of
building a 15 story Mega mosque named
quordoba which is which is which by the
way is Iconic of Islamic conquest on the
west looking down on the cemetery the
graveyard
ofo can I ask you a question yes sir
where is the proof that Muslims were
behind 9/11 where is your proof AMA
Osama Bin Laden said so Osama Bin Laden
has not even been charged with the crime
you can go in the lobby of
FBI has even been charged that the 19
hijackers were not I don't know how the
worst crime on American soil that they
say took place really the black
Holocaust but that they say took place
on American soil took place and nobody
has even been brought to trial and been
convicted of the crime
Zar wasn't even connected so where's the
proof the Muslims were behind 911 you're
not leaving stay with us sir but Andrea
um weigh in on this I mean this is a
really heated debate it always comes
down to people yelling accusations where
are you on this well the philosophy that
I'm getting from Mr shabbaz is more of a
philosophy of radical Islam we're
supposed to learn what they're doing
we're supposed to understand and they're
justified by flying planes into the
towers like he said because they were
mad they were having a bad day no I
didn't I did not say that
it most Pro that Muslims were involved
sir it's my turn please please moderate
Islam preaches tolerance moderate Islam
appeals to Muslims when they are the
minority in a society that is
predominantly non-muslim not to seow
Discord and not to divide you say this
is a bridge this is a oneway bridge and
there is proof there is proof that one
of the financiers gave money to a
terrorist organization that's the
Smoking Gun it's a question now hang
about this smoking gun about gun hang on
sir we got more a Smoking Gun for you
we'll get to your Smoking Gun in one
second but let me get to the penals go
ahead Joe you want to jump in Eric thank
you listen let's talk about the debate
let's be fair about what the issue is
here the issue is not lack of Tolerance
I don't think anybody on this panel
right or left correct me if I'm wrong is
suggesting that AAS should not be built
is that what the suggestion is I think
the suggestion is that it may be more
appropriate to build them mos in an area
which represents more sensitivity for
all and I think 9/11 should be taken as
an opportunity to do just that now to be
clear very quickly Eric the fact is is
that we have amendments we have a
constitution in this country that allows
us to exercise our rights to be free
freedom of speech and everything else
I'm with that amen however when you have
a mosque being built on Hollow ground
which is essentially a graveyard I think
it's fair for people to raise objections
and raise issues and say build a mosque
just not there one more guys get
understand and I can understand I was
with myab until he started to say that
Assam Bin Laden wasn't involved
September 11th I have no doubt of his
involvement I have no doubt of that
murder I guess I guess to to cite the
great philosopher Rodney King I want to
say why why can't we all get along
because here I hear from you and and the
guest and she Pam and you talk about the
fact that they're demanding Halal in
cafeteras what's so wrong with demanding
of I don't want to do this I want to get
to Mr sh please please hang hanging
there guys okay go ahead where's the
Smoking Gun sir here's opportunity
understand I understand you being I can
understand some being upset don't get me
wrong but be just as outraged that the
United States's best friends with Saudi
Arabia and Bush and the bin Laden family
have been in bed together and that Bin
Laden and the Taliban were funded by the
United States and the CIA sto the
hypocrisy over 9911 and look at the big
picture the United States is behind as
much as what you call terrorism
I invited you on I invited you on to
talk about the mosque to talk about the
issues I didn't invite you on to do some
911 truther pitch right here on my show
I don't like all no because because
you're blaming you're blaming the
Muslims for 9/11 and the proof is not so
clear others blame I'm not blaming
Muslims for not I'm not blaming moderate
Muslims I'm blaming
radical extremists for not anybody been
arrested why hasn't been anybody in
America been arrested for this
incredible act m
they flew into I'm the
inves all of a if they were from Saudi
Arabia if they were from Saudi Arabia
why do we still have relations solid all
engaged relations now you do have a
point because we buy a lot of oil from
Saudi Arabia that may have something to
go ahead p and that's that's where you
say clock is right twice a day look the
bottom line is is this was an act of War
this was an act of war and 3,000
precious Souls were slaughtered that day
in the name of Islam now not every
Muslim we're not blaming every Muslim he
sounds he sounds like he's blaming every
Muslim I have Muslims speaking at my
tomorrow I we may lose your satellite
window I apologize to you sir I'm not
cutting you off but here I have a
question for you you know you look at
Ford hood you look at Time Square bomber
you look at uh the zazi brothers in
Denver and queens these are radical
Muslim extremists these aren't
Christians these aren't Hindus they're
Muslim